until you can explain something to
somebody else you don't really
understand it this is one of the reasons
I suggest to people that they should do
a fake podcast with a friend for 30
minutes every week put one phone face
down on the table press the record
button just have a conversation pretend
that people are watching one of the
advantages of doing it for an audience
is that you actually feel like someone's
keeping you accountable interesting
quote from Wittgenstein Ludwig
Wittgenstein and he says the limits of
my language mean the limits of my world
a richer vocabulary means a richer life
first off the more words that you have
in your Arsenal the more precisely you
can describe the thing which is in your
head the more frictionlessly you can
take ideas from your brain to your mouth
your fingertips or the end of a pencil
the more accurately you're going to be
able to put that out into the world
right an idea is kind of like a smell
it's just a amorphous blob of a thing
until you make it take form through
spoken word written word or drawing it
doesn't really exist it's not tangible
you can't see it you can't work out
where the holes are in whatever this
idea is if you want to fully learn
something you want to spend time
synthesizing your ideas and you can
really only ever do that for somebody
else even if the audience is only five
people or only your friends